what's good mechanic boy chris ortiz and
today we have three very very special
ladies who are gonna cook for me three
very very special dishes and whoever
wins gets to go on a date with this
mexicano i'm chris ortiz i'm mexican i
like someone with a nice bubbly
personality someone who's genuine
someone who's nice was a big heart you
know because i have a big heart my name
is kelly i'm from los angeles california
i
am
mexican my mom's one of 14. eight of
them were born in mexico and my dad's
family is mexican indigenous mexican i
love that citrusy flavor in my furnace
now that so i'm going to add a lot of
orange juice
it's a workout i think we should cut a
little piece and try it
those are my tester tacos they're
perfect and they do the job
the dish i made is called tacos
i made them in a special way my grandma
you know i used to make this often like
all the time
all right i don't
i don't even want to look at it
because this looks amazing right now
first of all how did this woman know
that i love steak tacos oh okay
what is this because what is this
it's coffee it's coffee
jesus this oh you are something i don't
even drink coffee i'm not much of a
coffee drinker so that's fine that you
didn't know that but i do like to get
hyped so
look at that
oh my god wow
oh my god
this leads me to believe you're not only
mexican but some other latin country
because
we mexicans use white onions but there's
nothing wrong with this i rock with it
you already know girl oh
lady number one thank you for this i
think the tortillas are too chewy
i like the flavor and the seasoning and
the sear on this carne asada very nice
the only thing
that i would be like a little bit is
just that tortilla is just a little bit
too thick yeah i knew it especially if
it's your first time making it ain't
nothing wrong
this girl artistic
i have a feeling that she does
she either sings she either does poetry
yes come on chris for real definitely
not a basic girl because she came hard
and and heavy with these blue corn
tortillas now cabecito
i'm conflicted because it doesn't taste
a lot like coffee which is good because
i don't like coffee so i'm kind of like
do i like it but she went the extra mile
though oh
you go the extra mile right here
wow see she's not a basic girl she goes
she's artistic she's smart she's
out there because she can't
do wow points points
hi my name is kathy morla i am from
riverside california and i'm half
mexican my mom is mexican and she is
from san luis and my abuela actually has
her own little spices she likes to add
taste to her cooking i was just thinking
about how my grandma would feel right
now and she would be so proud of me i'm
so excited to show her what i did i
brought my specialty garnish out of the
nachos and then i also brought the chips
the sour cream the pico de gallo
homemade okay
i like the effort right unfortunately i
don't know how mexican nachos are i'm
good okay okay that's fine that's fine
that's why you could i like yeah it is
what it is she included jalapeno she
knows that i like the spice yes thank
you yeah now she didn't know this i hate
sour cream it's not her fault it's not
her fault my problem but i love sour
cream no
actually i'm actually looking forward to
this right now
when i first saw this dish
i was like i don't know about this
but now that i tasted it
now that i tasted it there we go it's
got some flavor
it's actually good it may not be the
most mexican thing but this is pretty
fire not gonna lie nacho girl
nacho girl
sorry i had to
those dad jokes just come too quick to
me you know i'm in love i'm in love
she's like your classic
girl you know what i mean like she knows
what's up she knows what she likes she
knows what she can make in the kitchen
and she goes and does it executes you
know the only thing i said is not the
most authentic mexican dish
the rephrase because it's not fair i'm
from mexico so it's like you know but
the refried beans could just use a
little bit more work but the carne asada
again i actually like the quality of
meat that she chose for this one the
other one was just a little too thin
this is the guy with a little more
thickness a little more spice
so i really i'm really digging the meat
on this one
not bad not bad hi my name is maria de
la ghetto i am from la my dad is mexican
american fifth generation los angeles
and my mom's filipina growing up in la i
went to all the carne asadas all the
barbecues i remember going to my
grandpa's house on sundays for posole
specifically this one time i remember
one of the fields was drinking a beer
and he poured it on the meat and i saw
that that was one of those corn memory
moments you know
so that's what i'm going to be making
today we're going to do a test
one first
my plate says organized chaos you know
there's a lot in there a lot going on
but it all comes together perfectly at
the end this third dish is the most
authentic looking
i feel like my aunt could have made this
or a prima because it's just
you know it i bet it tastes good i feel
like this person marches to the beat of
her own drum she does her own thing when
and if she wants to and however she
wants to so i kind of dig that she said
here you go chris it's going to be good
try it and i kind of like that power in
a woman she seems like a powerful woman
that's gonna you're gonna eat it and
you're gonna like it oh doesn't know me
so well
of course i gotta put the avocado in
there so shout out to her because she's
the only one to include avocado how
about that so right now brownie points
okay here we go
i feel like she's a busy girl too you
know what i mean she she is uh
doesn't like fluff it's straight to the
point let's get it i'm busy i got things
to do don't waste my time so i kind of
like that you know but the tortilla is
just a little stale the meat is just
really chewy so i feel like maybe where
not her fault wherever she got the meat
from is the issue not herself wherever
she bought it from
not the best mercado
whoa
whoa
she seasoned this meat with beer
the mexican way
oh my god she seasoned this with beer
and i
yo that just added more points because
that's how you do it in mexico yes
i love that i take that back i don't
know the thing is this taco is better
than that one congrats girl this has a
flavor this has everything i wanted
tastes delicious the only thing i can
complain about this i wish there was
more a way to a man's heart is through
his stomach this girl got there so
whoever this girl is trying where the
winner is
kelly
[Applause]
it's fine i get it she didn't though she
did it she's going to catch the bullet
but i want to leave thank you so much
i'm so grateful thank you
i'm glad you liked it
killing the game with these how do you
even make blue coins
excuse me
know how to dance a little bit okay
let's go
come on
[Music]
you